plusieurs mesures d'urgence évoqué ce
matin lors d'une séance de questions au
gouvernement dans une ambiance assez
étranger dans un hémicycle presque vide
alors une petite anecdote qui illustre
l'ambiance étrange qu'il y avait ce
matin au palais bourbon
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie agnès pannier hors énergie
a été prise d'une quinte de toux une
quinte de toux qui a été accueilli par
des sourires crispés dans un silence
assez inquiétant ça vous montre à quel
point cette séance ce matin était assez
particulière et puis comme on pouvait
s'y attendre toutes les questions
portait évidemment sur la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire sans précédent
avec notamment la question des masques
qui est revenu plusieurs fois le premier
ministre a été interpellé à plusieurs
reprises par tous les groupes présents
ici à l'assemblée nationale aussi bien
les socialistes que les républicains
olivier ferrand a tenté de déminer la
polémique sur le manque de matériel en
pointant du doigt une décision des
gouvernements précédents et puis un peu
plus tard matt hill panneau du groupe
elle est fille a demandé la création
d'un comité parlementaire de suivi
permanent pour dit elle plus de
transparence dans l'action du
gouvernement dans la gestion de cette
crise alors ensuite cette séance de
questions au gouvernement a dû riquet a
duré à peu près une heure et demie a été
suivie dans l'après midi par une séance
cette fois ci pour examiner le projet de
loi de finances rectificative pardon le
gouvernement a annoncé qu'ils allaient
intégrer un plan de soutien de 45,1
milliards d'euros une première mesure
qui sera le report des charges fiscales
et sociales pour toutes les entreprises
sur le mois de mars c'est la déclaration
de bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie il a également évoqué la
création d'un fonds de solidarité visant
à soutenir les plus petites entreprises
les indépendants et les
micro-entreprises alors le député
charles de courson du groupe liberté et
territoires a estimé que l'hypothèse
d'un confinement d'un mois était un peu
trop optimiste nicolas dupont aignan de
la france de 2000 à 2001 france pardon a
dénoncé quant à lui le manque
d'anticipation du gouvernement dans
cette crise alors les débats se
poursuivent et les députés ont
semble-t-il vous
montré en tout cas aujourd'hui qu'il
prenait à coeur à cette crise qui frappe
la france aujourd'hui alors que le virus
se propage à grande vitesse merci dit la
faam ont joué